salut moi c'est ahmed je suis
journaliste j'habite la cité
pablo-picasso à nanterre depuis 20 ans
vous savez les tours nuage vous les avez
sûrement déjà aperçu un ensemble de 18
immeubles l'oeuvre de l'architecte emile
aillaud dans les années 70 dans le
quartier on en rigole encore
l'architecte il a dû en fumée de la
bonne lors de la conception des
bâtiments des tours en forme de tuyaux
sans angle droit beaucoup de couleurs
des fenêtres en forme de cube lot de
paquebots ou encore deux gouttes d'eau
ou de feuilles d'arbres pour plus de
douceur
blague à part moi j'ai trop jolie mais
tour nuage d'ailleurs elles sont été
labellisé patrimoine du xxème siècle
s'il vous plaît
l'objectif c'était de loger les familles
d'ouvriers dans autre chose que des
boîtes à chaussures données de la beauté
aux plus modestes oui à la cité pablo
picasso on ne roule pas sur l'or une
bonne partie de la population vit en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
mêlée pablo comme on les appelle sont
très attachés à leur quartier
ça c'est le serpent une sculpture géante
dans laquelle les enfants jouent sans se
faire peur enfin un jouet avec le
coronavirus interdiction d'utiliser les
aires de jeux jusqu'à nouvel ordre
la crise sanitaire est passée par là
alors j'ai décidé de vous faire
découvrir ma cité confiné comment vit-on
le confinement dans ce quartier
populaire on ira à la rencontre de la
famille zaoui
et de la famille collard on rencontrera
samir sans papiers et sans abri il ya
aussi abdel l'épicier du quartier le roi
du gestes barrières monsieur
et enfin cassis de l'association faire
le bien tu as mis des phares 12
l'écumé de bois peu ternie
allez suivez moi
[Musique]
dans la famille zaoui je demande yolande
la maman
ange l'aîné anderson aminata et moussa
malik le petit dernier
yolande élève seule ses quatre enfants
dans cet appartement f4 ce soir là elle
prépare du riz gras un incontournable de
la cuisine ivoirienne son pays d'origine
du ried et thomas des petits pois des
carottes et du poulet à plat simple pas
trop d'ingrédients c'est que depuis le
début du confinement le budget
nourriture du foyer a explosé c'est très
dur
parce que
les enfants ils savent pas ils sont tous
dans la cuisine entre les griots t on ce
matin sans le soin
qu'on s'ennuie il vient et thoune à la
cuisine
oublier les tâches et les gâteaux ou le
goûter sinon
alors par précaution et yolande a fait
des réserves des aliments de première
nécessité en priorité
oui il faut rappeler parce que ça va
vite le yahoo teint l'aîné saucisses
jambon les enfants consomment beaucoup
yolande et agents des services
hospitaliers elle nettoie les hôpitaux
et distribuer les repas aux patients en
ce moment au chômage elle a décidé de
rester à la maison pour s'occuper des
enfants pendant la crise sanitaire elle
perçoit 1000 euros de pôle emploi
auxquels s'ajoutent 700 euros
d'allocations familiales un budget total
de 1700 euros pour 5 personnes trop
juste surtout qu'avec le confinement l'a
constaté les prix dans les épiceries du
quartier ont augmenté y'a plus être
moins cher
vous pu trouver les liquides vaisselle 2
ce qui coûte 1 euro inquiète mais tu
trouveras de 0,99 les oeufs sont devenus
à 5 euros
tout est cher tout devient cher et c'est
moi pourquoi ils font ça
yolande à une crainte attrapé le virus
et le transmettre aux enfants alors tout
le monde reste confinée à la maison on
ne sort pratiquement pas les enfants
font souvent collés à leur smartphone
moussa le petit dernier a trouvé
l'astuce pour canaliser l'énergie
débordante de ses sept ans un jeu sur la
télé avec youtube élastique forte knight
et vous allez le voir sa twingo
[Musique]
les rares fois où yolande sort d'or pour
faire les courses par exemple elle l'a
remarqué
l'ambiance a changé dans les mairies 6e
que tu vois quelqu'un il ne dit même pas
bonjour chacun
en fait chacun un peu de chacun
ils ont peur d'être contaminés on sait
pas qui est malade on sépare donc
même quand il ya une personne a un sens
et une autre à fond nos musées
d'attendre la peur de monter et puis il
ya ces moments de spiritualité la
famille zaoui et pratiquante chrétienne
évangéliste la soirée se termine par une
prière avec une attention particulière
pour le personnel soignant seigneur nous
voulons te dis merci pour cette journée
seigneur était à nous te confions les
médecins les infirmiers des aides
soignantes entre tam en seigneur gadley
protège les amène
[Musique]
cette fois on va rendre visite à la
famille collard le papa daniel et
retraités il élève seul lui aussi ses
deux filles oui beaucoup de familles
monoparentales dans le quartier même si
elles ont chacune leur chambre ça se
chamaille
toujours en vadrouille alors à tous on
voit donc
ses copines l'a1 donc en fait ce qu'on
filme ans et vous vous retrouvez quoi
pour le pays voilà
j'aimerai bien sortir mais pas sortir
que une heure je ressortirai vraiment
toute la journée
être avec mes copines et tous vivement
que ça se termine vite moment soit en en
mâchant pas tellement donc
là j'ai mon chien du coup là j'assume
mon chien
je les comprends il tourne en rond dans
la baraque des pays bas qui se prennent
la tête tous les deux la grande et la
petite oie l'autre à la battant l'autre
salat raison alors ça ça va pas sympa
alors des fois je les lola gta
permettent
la callas qui a cassé deux films sur le
palier la nasa va faire parce que trop
semaine je n'ai pas internet pour le
comprendre mes clients
heureusement il reste le téléphone
portable la maman dit dans le sud de la
france qu'on aime en
ald evina veulent à rejoindre cet été
pour les vacances
passées enfin si c'est possible
[Musique]
les enfants moins deux mois et demi
parce que
[Musique]
déby sera pas
mes parents je t'aime
et il n'ya pas chaldée nina qui n'en
peut plus avec le confinement le pape a
aussi a vu ses habitudes le symbole et
le problème c'est les amis il a
fait l'ena qui m'a téléphoné bibi là il
m'a téléphoné et m'a dit à daniel sala
je vois savoir je fais toi à nier c'est
daniel on a enfermé les boulons n'est
pas prêt de journaux là je fais faut
qu'on essaie de faire passer on verra
bien on est chez nous et on tourne en
rond
[Musique]
à nanterre la population se confine à la
maison pour se protéger du coronavirus
mais quand on n'a pas deux maisons où
les commet et soudain samir me vient à
l'esprit je l'avais croisé dans les rues
de nanterre il ya un an samir et sans
papiers il est sans abri aussi la double
peine en cette période de confinement
direction un parking à deux pas de chez
moi il m'a donné rendez vous à 7 heures
du matin à l'heure du réveil une de ses
connaissances lui a prêté ce renault
espace en panne trop pouvoir dormir il à
calfeutrer les vitres avec du tissu et
du carton il a passé la nuit enroulée
dans une couette
les cje arrière dégagé voilà pour le lit
de fortune cela fait six mois que samir
de récits rester confiné c'est le mot
d'ordre des autorités mais comment
rester chez soi quand on n'a pas de chez
soi
ça me rend confiant pour moi parce que
bon le confinement c'est quoi c'est de
rester chez g soit prendre soin et vt de
d'être regroupés selon à mélanger tout
ça compte de chaque malade et pour moi
ça n'existe pas comment je me confie
nous
confiance et d'or à la rue dans des
petits coins par sait pas alors
attention et à contrôler qui te caches
tu reviens à chaque fois c'est comme ça
samir ses farces tous les jours de
maintenir une hygiène dans son lieu de
confinement dehors aussi même si c'est
pas évident
là quand je me réveille j'ai ma
bouteille d'eau
je me lave avec ça je bois et j'en mange
mes affaires je sors d'or
c'est toujours un problème parce que là
ils ont tous fermé mama même des douches
des sanitaires des trucs déjà pour se
laver il est huit heures du matin le
moment de quitter le véhicule c'est vrai
journée d'hier a tranché
s'ensuit une balade dans la rue pour se
dégourdir les jambes le petit déj on
oublie les cafés sont fermés alors il se
pose souvent le portable à la main pour
avoir des nouvelles de la famille samir
a quitté l'algérie il y a deux ans là je
prends des nouvelles de ma mère elle est
très inquiète pour moi en fait j'essaie
toujours de la rassurer comme ça
j'espère qu'à voir un petit peu trompeur
et voilà que la crise sanitaire rend
visible ce qui était jusque là invisible
on ne voit plus qu'eux car il n'ya plus
que dehors sans attestation car sans
papiers il faut jouer au chat et à la
souris avec la police c'est au petit
bonheur la chance avec le confinement
les contrôles d'identité sont plus
nombreux bon il va te faire
un à dix on s'est trompé gentil que ça
et va te dire de quitter les lieux ok
monsieur je vais quitter les lieux mais
pour aller où c'est à chaque fois c'est
la même chose je vais aller au moins bah
voilà monsieur vous vous mettez à
l'extrême et et d'un autre département
on va dire l'essentiel que on vous
trouve pas nous
moi j'ai mon fils de puteaux et nanterre
à nanterre c'est la même chose journée
un plutôt bon ça il est 18 heures ce
jour-là samir croise pascal à voisins du
quartier on se raconte la galère du
confinement samir nous confiera qu'il
n'a pas peur du virus mais de la police
est de ne plus avoir d'argent il avait
l'habitude de travailler au noir pour
survivre aujourd'hui il est fauché par
l'arrêt de l'économie bat avant on
pouvait au moins des parlers dans le
bâtiment par exemple les marchés les
déménagements mais avec centre rien
faire on évoquait tout est bloqué à plus
travail à plus de rien
c'est mort et il faut passer le temps
dans la rue
avant le début de la nuit
[Musique]
samir est un confiné dehors
sur l'avenue déserté avec le confinement
une oasis
l'épicerie déstockage c'est le quartier
en miniature on s'y bouscule malgré la
nécessaire distance sociale
est obligé de prendre l'habitude ça
parce que c'est trop notre vie en jeu
c'est pas la santé ici le boss si
abdellah et gare à vous si vous ne
respectez pas les gestes barrière
monsieur
nous attendait d'abord votre tour
restait à l'éclat d'un délit distance
entre vous s'il vous plaît madame voilà
6 euros c
130h très con saxo du second acte c'est
mieux apparemment il y en a que pour eux
c'est rien du tout ils oublient ils
rentrent sont demandés
y en a qui s'énerve font rien parce
qu'ils attendent longtemps l'autre et là
prix du thon et au magasin y en a qui
sont stressés et prennent n'importe quoi
ils servent pas qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
repris
il ya le panic des fois vraiment rien à
pain est un art qui sont en train de
paniquer il y en a qui ils sont cools
pour moi non je ne veux pas parler pour
les autres mais certains ils ont abusé
de la
de la situation ils ont avisé
un pack d'eau est passée à 2 50 au lieu
de un euro 31 euros 20 euros 50 les
hommes aussi ça dépasse c'est des heures
on north a apparemment madame jean prix
ici les clients sont un peu perdus sur
la suite des événements en colère aussi
c'est un grande abondance et du côlon
grand n'importe quoi ce qui se passe en
fait pourquoi on pousse les gens à aller
voter en dix ans ferme l'école est
maintenant d'essayer d'ouvrir des écoles
où je suis pas prête à envoyer mes
enfants après si cette paix pour pousser
les parents allaient travailler à ce
moment là il faut trouver une autre
solution on dit que les enfants sans les
premiers à véhiculer la maladie après
les enseignants ils vont faire commander
des classes de 30 élèves en fait on va
faire comment concrètement les masques
on n'en trouve pas les masques on n'en
trouve pas alors il ya le système des
délais fabrique c'est quoi je sais pdg
les plus
géniaux de cluny à des mouchoirs
radiateur
abdel se considère comme un soldat en
guerre contre le coc vie 19 il tient à
rester ouverts pour ses clients même si
la peur d'attraper le virus vous leur
ajoutons plus retiennent du monde est
toujours le masque avec dégoût et l
échange tous les deux heures à peu près
ce soir que je veux rentrer chez moi
c'est la pire des choses
j'enlève tous mes affaires devant la
porte dans un sac
et ça se lave toujours jeu j'ai peur de
ramener la mort à mes enfants wes
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui avec le
confinement
am de la ctc calque
[Musique]
cinquième semaine de confinement les
écoles sont fermées l'enseignement se
fait à distance le maintien de la
continuité pédagogique coûte que coûte a
dit le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
comment ça se passe à nanterre allez
venez avec moi on va retrouver à la
famille zaoui
chez les as oui on se lève comme pour un
jour d'école bonjour dit comment vas tu
as bien dormi c anderson le plus grand
qui chapeaute les de loire du petit
dernier en ce1
ce jour là on découvre ensemble le
message du maître de moussa j'en profite
pour remercier tous les parents
je vous
enverrai le corriger en fin de journée
comme je voulais souvent
à la maison on a établi un programme de
travail il ya un travail d'écriture
chaque jour les offres devront faire une
ou deux pages de leurs cahiers
d'écriture il n'est pas nécessaire
lenteur plus il faut pas tuer la qualité
à la quantité non satisfait s'ajouter
dans les tâches
écrit avec eux ont reçu notification qui
3,5 à 3,7 cahiers et après on commence à
faire les devoirs étaient confinés dans
votre photo au point que les trucs qu'on
prend
ici le confinement révèle la fracture
numérique chez les as oui il n'ya qu'un
seul ordinateur pour quatre élèves à la
maison alors yolande doit organiser le
roulement le matin les deux points qui
font les devoirs avec le pc portable
pour pouvoir laisser l'ordinateur aux
deux plus grands à l'après midi
donc je mets la presse confirmant parce
que je n'en menais pas fait sa gloire à
plus grands il fallait renvoyer les des
voix le prof a
voulu comprendre comment ça se fait que
vous
il y a les obstacles matériels il y a le
niveau scolaire aussi violente s'appuie
sur les aînés pour faire l'école sans
eux elle n'y arriverait pas fait bien
les choses je paie des moussaillons les
adultes je peux pas les aider parce
qu'ils sont au collège je suis arrivé au
collège donc c'était du mois difficiles
comment les coachs et comment voir si
l'on fait les devoirs 1,6 à y coller
d'anglais prépare et louis xi combattre
les inégalités sociales et scolaires
était déjà difficile dans une salle de
classe l'exercice s'avère plus périlleux
encore avec l'enseignement à distance et
pourtant vous ça s'applique dans le
travail d'écriture un seul roi du qu'un
minuscule ferme les yeux du peuple il
faut appliquer silencieux
malgré les obstacles et yolande met un
point d'honneur à ce que les enfants ne
décroche pas pendant le confinement
je veux que mes enfants et mes veines
quelqu'un réside en fait un bon boulot
il faut que
c'est très important pour
qu'ils arrivent un peu loin
m.moussa
parce que il est devenu conduit 2 tu
aimes tu as fait mois plus tard
conduite à d'être
violent nous confiera qu'elle enverra
ses enfants à l'école lors du
déconfinement à partir du 11 mai parce
qu'il faut bien qu'il reste au niveau
elle ne cache pas non plus un sentiment
d'angoissé
ce jour là daniel collard le papa des
deux filles seront au pied d'une tour au
pablo picasso pour la distribution
alimentaire
c'est là que se trouve le local de
l'association faire le bien son
président ces cas si
[Musique]
daniel collard perçoit 700 euros de
retraite ces fines des jeunes plus à la
cantine il faut les nourrir tous les
midis un surcoût insurmontable
cette distribution c'est sa seule
planche de salut
des fans wasps sont durs j'ai quand même
de gosse j'ai tout seul et si à payer
fait pas mal de trucs ap à l'art libre
rester grand chose
c'est pour ça je me suis cassé
vous des du pain quand sa maman vont
donner
dans le quartier la crise sanitaire se
double d'une crise sociale la demande
alimentaire explose et la file d'attenté
grossi au fur et à mesure
je t'ai titre très content je ne sais
pas si les restos du coeur de votre pc
mais ici on a aussi pensé à apporter son
kit de protection
c'est pour protéger
la mue
les bénéficiaires sont convoquées avant
par téléphone pour éviter la cohue est
respectée les east barrière malgré tout
cas ci est obligés de refuser du monde
axel
a aujourd'hui
heureusement on n'a pas beaucoup de
marchandises on a convoqué déjà pas mal
de personnes demain demain ou après
demain ok ok allez au revoir merci ouais
madame ehrlich aujourd'hui y'a pas
demain ou mercredi ouais
l'association permet de nourrir
habituellement 300 familles à nanterre
toute l'année avec la crise sanitaire
ses soixante familles de plus qui
s'ajoute mais ce qu'il ya de nouvelles
personnes bas quelques vins qui sont
envoyées par les assistantes sociales
sondages les premiers pas vraiment c'est
clair que les gens ils sont plus dans le
besoin mais taylor de ruine les gars de
lui voilà un peu un peu de un peu de
moutarde un peu de moutarde voilà donc
les gens ils viennent basse et des
débuts on a plaidé jean yves n'est pas
parce qu'ils avaient peur et puis
finalement ça c'est des comptes est un
petit peu
cassis est parti tôt le matin récupérer
les denrées alimentaires des invendus
dans les grandes surfaces
en bas de ça qu'ils ont fermé à 10 ans
acquise
mettez des glaces montée des eaux au
frigo
chaque colis alimentaires à une valeur
de 50 euros environ généralement une
participation de 5 euros étaient
demandées aux bénéficiaires avec le
confinement c'est totalement gratuit
c'est beaucoup des familles
monoparentales
donc c'est des familles pour certains
très nombreuses 7 8 personnes l'un des
enfants surtout et sinon il ya beaucoup
de retraités ya beaucoup de gens qui
n'ont pas de domicile des sdf il ya
beaucoup de mal heureusement des gens
qui n'ont pas de papiers donc ils ont
rien à manger ils sont confinés donc
cela effectivement assez assistante
sociale qui nous oriente il vient d'un
peu partout
bonjour c'est quoi votre prénom
samir maintenant il doit nous
revoilà samir confiné dehors il ne
connaissait pas l'association faire le
bien nous l'avons orienté vers cassis va
pouvoir s'inscrire voilà donc là
exceptionnellement je vous fais un colis
d'urgence mais après si vous voulez
bénéficier tout le temps des colis
faudrait me ramener quelques documents
quand même au moins la photocopie du
passeport
l'attestation de domiciliation
alors
les croissants
pour tous à confiture non le lait les
oeufs les denrées périssables pas
conservable samir ne peut pas les
prendre et pour cause comme je suis à la
rue je dors dans une voiture que ça ça
sert à rien de prendre du lait ou que je
vois que
mieux ne pas les prendre chacun d'aller
font que jeter ou les laisser comme ça
trois sont
du chocolat pour ça ça va je peux
vraiment lui conserver
l'esprit pour au moins deux jours ça va
m'aider un peu un au revoir au courant
son cabas bien remplie samir va pouvoir
tenir plusieurs jours grâce à
l'association il a beau ne pas avoir de
papiers cas ci va fermer les yeux samir
pourra recevoir d'autres colis
alimentaires et les semaines suivantes
[Musique]
cette nuit là des jeunes ont tiré des
mortiers d'artifices des gros pétards
sur la police devant la cité il y a eu
des feux de poubelles aussi un accident
de moto impliquant un jeune et la police
en plein confinement à villeneuve la
garenne voisine a mis le feu aux poudres
les incidents sporadiques qui se sont
vite calmées ce n'est pas l'image que je
garderai de ma cité confiné
moi ce que je garde c'est cette image
plutôt
nanterre comme le reste de la france
tous les soirs à 20h
l'hommage au personnel soignant
est-ce qu'on travaille très difficiles à
vaincre les entourages et
[Musique]
dans ma cité confiné à nanterre comme
dans d'autres quartiers populaires la
crise du coville 19 agit comme un
révélateur des inégalités
[Musique]
c'est aussi l'émergence de nouvelles
solidarités
[Musique]